people in the u.s are dealing with als
or lou gehrig's disease as it's
sometimes called you can help some of
the nevadans affected by als at a
fundraiser going on don newberg is the
executive director of the als
association nevada chapter she's here to
talk about the event don it's good to
see you it's really good to see you too
and thank you so much for having me this
is such an important topic it is and you
guys have an event going on at a pizza
place right yeah we do on monday night
best way to start your week i guess is
to go to monzu and support your local
als association
they're opening their restaurants
starting at six o'clock and um they are
going to be
it's from six to ten actually i'll food
i'll drink there's going to be live
music there's a silent auction all the
proceeds will go to our organization
yeah i read it 75 bucks and that at 8
o'clock reservations cut off right they
do and but it's open till 10. so if you
come in at 8 you're there until 10.
that's fantastic and this goes toward a
lot of things that you guys do for
families that are impacted by als what
are some of those things absolutely so
currently about 120 individuals in
nevada we support with um with support
services we have a multi-disciplinary
clinic where brings all the disciplines
together you know individuals with als
uh
there's no cause there's no cure the
average lifespan is about two to five
years
the cost out of pocket is about two
hundred fifty thousand dollars per
family
through their journey so we provide
services that really help the families
with transportation i'm getting to
clinic on time being able to to meet
with their speech therapist occupational
therapists all of the things they need
to do
as well as just
support care and support we have support
groups on thursday nights or for all of
our patients and families and just
bringing people together
to understand until there is a cure for
this disease to help them along their
journey i love that concept because the
caregivers also go through so much and
for them to have a support group is
vital absolutely and we provide respite
care as well so that the caregivers can
take time away we can bring licensed
professionals into people's homes to be
able to help the the family get some
time away
it's a horrible diagnosis and it's
something that
the whole community needs to get
together to be able to support nevadans
that are on this journey yeah because
all those things we discussed obviously
take funding and so that's what this
event is all about tell us again where
and when so it's monday night it starts
at six o'clock um it's at monzu where's
that um it's it's on flamingo yes and
chef geo has
closed the restaurant so anybody that
signs up for tickets will be those
individuals that are there it's not
going to be open to the public like i
said all proceeds from this event do go
to our organization and without
community support being the only
non-profit in the state of nevada that
helps families with als we need that
community support don newberg thank you
for all you do in the community really
appreciate it thank you so much for
having me yeah and just to remind you
again the als association nevada chapter
fundraiser happens at monzu italian oven
and bar again it's monday august 29th
starting at six tickets are 75 bucks and
100 of that goes to als nevada and monzu
is donating all the food the labor and
gratuities from the event to